do you have any memories of dad honestly
all that i have to describe him as is
basically what he did
we all have a glorified idea of who alex
was
never really had a need to go digging
through all these memories
until your kid comes along decides to
make a documentary about you
i was 10 years old on october 5th 1999.
we looked up and we saw that an
avalanche had triggered
it should have been me survivor skill is
a bear
avalanche high in the himalayas killing
the best of our time alex lowe
his body was never recovered
it's like an astronaut lost in space
i had these three kids life was going
really fast
[Music]
i can remember conrad arriving on my
doorstep i mean what could i do for alex
what could i do to take care of all of
you
you were upset with me at first you
didn't take to conrad like your brother
conrad's the only dad i've ever known
maybe less so for you since you had four
more years of knowing alex
you are my son
i have no other family this is my family
conrad got a phone call he told me
it has to be him
it was like he came back to life
he showed up
[Music]
we have this shadow of alex hangs over
all of us
[Music]
you ever think you're gonna have to
confront the
body of your hero
[Music]
you can
lose someone and still love someone else
i guess i'm curious as to why you want
to make this film considering it's
something that we have explored with
just ourselves
i feel like it's going to bring things
out in the open and then we'll just see
if we can recover from that